all right good morning it's a pretty
good turnout thank you so much for
coming my eyes are a little red and
blurry this morning not because I've
been up all night drinking fine wine in
Sonoma
but because I woke up with a slight eye
irritation so I got have my slides here
my notes here so I could see them and if
at any point I'm no longer facing the
audience during my talk if you could be
so kind as just to give me like a polite
shout out and let me know where you're
at just kidding this is not that bad
anyway I'm Austin Collins I guess I'm an
instigator of this serverless movement I
in 2015 I created a very popular
open-source project called the
surrealist framework and this is an
application framework that allows you to
build apps exclusively on servlet
infrastructure like AWS lambda and I
think that this framework in particular
had a lot to do in showing the world
kind of how powerful this technology and
this trend can be I'm also the founder
and CEO of a startup called Cerberus Inc
were based in San Francisco we make
tools and services to help developers
and teams build and operate service
applications regardless of platform and
our company is also helping out with the
standardization efforts happening within
the CNC F around serverless concepts
which I'll dig into later in this talk
anyway this is serverless
state-of-the-union special open source
edition special exclusive in this talk
we're gonna analyze what's happening in
the service world we're gonna try and
forecast you know what's gonna happen
next and we're gonna discuss leveraging
open source to smartly adopt service
today so let's get started
boom amidst containers orchestrators VMs
paths at a left field out of nowhere
basically came this this serverless
trend I don't think anyone was really
expecting it and it picked up momentum
rapidly it has won hearts and minds and
developers and it's not slowing down we
clearly have a trend here on our hands
and now what's the big deal why why is
why is this trend catching on why is
this important so first off to clarify
if you aren't already aware serverless
means that those servers exist
developers don't have to think about
them
not a very technically accurate term
it's about as technically accurate as
the term the cloud I'd say but once you
say once you say that word to a
developer and you see that enthusiasm
that it invokes that emotional response
that you know there's there's no there's
no reason why it's easy to recognize why
this buzzword caught on why it is the
buzzword because it invokes all the
right emotions and it's all about you
know using tools using infrastructure
that get out of your way so that you
could focus on solving business problems
and this simple idea has been around for
a long time and obviously has has mass
appeal and this simple idea you know a
reason why we we get why this has become
such a big trend is that because first
off this does a great job of solving
ancient problems in our service
framework we have significant enterprise
adoption and when these users come to us
we always ask them you know why are you
here what's so interesting about this to
you and they always tell us the same you
know that they looking to solve the same
problems that is number one they want to
move fast they want to reduce time to
market number two they want to increase
innovation they're saying heck our
competitors are moving very fast our
competitors are doing all these cool
things we want to do the same and they
also want to reduce operational overhead
of course and reduce cost and despite
how far we've come with how is so much
great change in innovation in IT we
still have not solved these ancient
problems yet and the serverless movement
is kind of a testament to that
and it's why Sir bliss has has picked up
so much momentum at the same time
serverless solves new problems problems
that are just starting to come into
fruition and I don't know how to
characterize these more concisely than
to say you know the the digital world is
storming into reality
right now we've got Internet of Things
devices everywhere with sensors
collecting all types of data generating
big data we got machine learning
artificial intelligence infused into all
this building systems of intelligence
systems that can make decisions in real
time at creating autonomous machines
self-driving cars we've got computing
running in the edge all over the place
Voice devices technology is is
everywhere
and if you're a business you have to pay
attention to all this because your
competitors are and amidst these ancient
problems and all these new problems you
know one of course has to ask themselves
a very important question and that is do
you really want to be running your own
infrastructure is that kind of a good
position for you right now is that kind
of the gonna be on the right side of
history that choice and that's you know
I think you could see where the people
in the service movement stand but
they're you know they're very nervous
about burdening themselves with this
especially in this era of upcoming hyper
innovation and hyper competition so
servlets a brief history I'm not gonna
go into pass I'm just gonna start with
the serverless trend starting back in
2014 this kind of got kicked off with
Amazon Web Services when they came out
with a new way to do compute in the
cloud called AWS lambda and in the early
days you know they were kind of
marketing this as glue code as
event-driven code and it was very
limited the use cases were very limited
but at the core there was a
revolutionary way to do compute and it
was revolutionary because all you had to
do as a developer was upload some code
and you'd write this code in the form of
a function enough code to perform one
task like save a user to a database or
send out a transactional email you'd
upload that code to AWS lambdas platform
and that would create an AWS lambda
function this independent unit of
deployment and this function would
require very little to zero
administration the provider handles
everything and it scales automatically
to meet massive levels of concurrency
and also aid abuse lambda had this paper
execution paper use pricing model that
was incredibly efficient and this cannot
be understated when people come join the
service movement it's this pricing model
that really brings them through the door
and then they kind of stay for once they
look at all these qualities together
they realize that there is a lowest
total cost of ownership scenario here
that is absolutely compelling but this
pricing model is super important you're
not going to get charged unless your
code runs and when you do get charged
you get charged at 100 millisecond
increments very exciting and lastly this
code is event-driven these functions
will spin up to handle any type of
events
of events mostly coming from the
underlying platform so when something
happens in your AWS s3 bucket it'll
automatically trigger a function or when
a record gets saved to a dynamodb table
it'll trigger a function or an HTTP web
request in the service world even these
HTTP requests are being considered as as
events so back in back in 2015 you know
aw slam that the use cases were very
limited that you know it was I don't
think it had great packaging I don't
think it had a great developer
experience and it certainly was not
being considered as an application
platform and this is where kind of our
company stepped in you know we came out
to try and define the application
experience around AWS lambda because at
the core we saw that revolutionary
compute service and we won't basically
wanted to use it for everything right
and we needed some tooling to enable
that so we started working on this
surplice framework mid-2015 and it
solves a lot of problems that need to be
solved if you want to build service
architectures most importantly when you
build a service architecture it's pretty
complicated first off you have all these
independent units of deployment all
these functions and there are a lot of
these this is very much like a
traditional kind of micro service
architecture however the difference in
the service world is that the overhead
burden is not there with these surplice
functions because the provider is
managing scale managing you know all
aspects of administration and what
happens and what we see regularly is
that people who are doing service
development could be one or two
engineers and their provisioning
hundreds of these functions it's pretty
awesome it's all because that overhead
burden is not there so you have a whole
bunch of functions a whole bunch of
independent units of deployment and all
these functions have infrastructure
dependencies they need infrastructure to
trigger the functions via events and
they also need infrastructure to perform
their business logic whether it's a
database caching mechanism or storage
anyway so we looked at all this in the
early days we said you know this there's
there's a there's an application story
here that's that's pretty compelling and
how can we express this in a simpler
format so that people don't have to
think about things in this very
complicated way so the one thing that I
think the service framework did very
well is they said look
this is cerberus is simply a story of
functions and events and that's what we
presented to developers so we gave them
a simple configuration file you could
list all your functions containing your
business logic and every single function
in that configuration file could have an
events property and you could list their
all the events that would trigger that
function all the events that happen in
your digital business in this this whole
experience was very very compelling the
users all they'd have to do is type
service deploy and the service framework
will go provision all the infrastructure
necessary and wire it up so that it
works together in this event-driven
model and the user and the developers
won't have to think about that as much
so again I think this open source
project had a lot to do and kind of show
in the world the service architecture
introducing the service application to
the world and up next in 2016 given the
massive success of AWS lambda a lot of
the other public cloud providers took
note and they started to offer very
similar services Google came out with
Google Cloud functions as sure came out
as your functions IBM came out with IBM
cloud functions and overall these
service functions also known as
functions as a service they're a great
way to use these cloud platforms they're
a great way to adopt cloud platforms if
you want to use a cloud platform and
gain access to all the cool services
that that cloud platform offers stick a
function there it's auto-scaling you
know it's paper execution it's a very
very trivial way to start leveraging
leveraging that cloud platform and this
is this is exciting because I think that
this is gonna enable more venture a
vendor choice and multi provider
capability in the future in 2016 we also
saw more open source heroes enter the
scene and they started coming out with
open source versions of servos compute
platforms essentially and these projects
seek to give organizations the ability
to make their own service computing
platforms
you know largely based on containers and
kubernetes we've got great projects in
this space like cublas Oracles FN
project there's open faz and ibm's open
whisk and a lot more these things are
popping up a lot right now there
probably be two more by tomorrow now in
this scenario you're still managing your
own infrastructure right you kind of
bring one of these in your organism
you have a few people operating the
service platform and it's their job to
expose it to developers so developers
can focus on solving business problems
with the least amount of friction so is
it service I don't know but but what it
does borrow heavily from the cloud
experience is that application
experience is emulated in these
platforms that simple story of functions
and events these things can be perceived
as past 2.0 and one of the biggest
changes is simply this model of doing
things it's a simple story of functions
and events and now you could kind of
self host this anywhere you want and
that's that's pretty exciting in 2017 we
started to see the you know the surplice
term continue to grow and all of a
sudden a lot of cloud infrastructure
beyond computing was being called
serverless Amazon kind of took the lead
on this they started referring to kind
of their traditional SAS products as
serverless so AWS s3 which has been
around for a very long time they've
started to call that serverless SNS
they're starting to call that server
list a lot of their new services like
their Aurora database is now being
referred to as serverless and a lot of
these independent SAS providers are kind
of using the term service to refer to
their to their products like algo leah
I've seen them do this off zero and
that's pretty interesting I think it has
some implications for the service
application in general and the service
application now is kind of being
perceived as using service compute and
pairing it with infrastructure that has
these service qualities auto-scaling you
know paper use and combining these
things together to make end results or
applications that have extremely low
total cost of ownership their paper
execution their auto scaling they're
almost like set it and forget it and
these applications are very efficient
and and very powerful so that's what has
happened here's here's kind of what's
happening now and and some things to pay
attention to there's there's clearly a
collision happening between server lists
computing functions as a service and
containers I think it's getting a bit
awkward actually
traditionally containers offered great
isolation you know packaging portability
but not lo late
the provisioning or an efficient pricing
model for running them in the cloud
meanwhile AWS lambda offered low latency
provisioning runtimes ready to go sub
second billing and this simple kind of
functional model in the service world
people have been using both these things
for different use cases containers have
been great for asynchronous long running
tasks and functions are great for short
tasks where you don't have to think
where you don't want to have to kind of
think about containers only the business
logic and how you and if you want to
benefit from that efficient pricing
model but now containers as a service
are looking more like serverless
container platforms as your container
service has a per second building model
you know no virtual machine management
AWS has Fargate you know it's a managed
container platform also at the per
second billing model both these are
going to continue to probably collide
and exist and evolve and this is still
the beginning of this story but it's
certainly something to watch furthermore
software as a service is it continues to
expand and this is important because SAS
is value on top of service computing
cannot be understated in the early days
of the service framework we noticed
amazing innovation and creativity coming
from the users and first off it's
because you know when you reduce
operational overhead you liberate a lot
of productivity and you also liberate
creativity but a lot of this also came
from simply pairing kind of servos
compute from pairing AWS lambda with
other kind of sass other serverless
infrastructure and we kind of realized
that the lambdas only half the value
you've got to have other great service
like infrastructure to pair it with to
build these these end results these
applications it's a very exciting time
because you know a lot more sass is
coming the cloud providers are
aggressively innovating new products
with SAS models and so are startups so
you know Amazon of course has s3
DynamoDB lambda they have the new Aurora
they've got comprehend their natural
language processing service they've got
transcribed for speech recognition I
mean while Google has a ton of cool
cloudy eye products like cob speech
translation their vision API video
intelligence API is that whole cloud AI
category I think is just going to
explode will continue to explode and you
know overall this is this is exciting
this is like the Golden Age
of software development I mean never has
there been this like greater time to be
able to use all these kind of these
pieces of infrastructure to make things
faster to make things at scale to get
your vision out there and make some type
of meaning in the world so overall this
is you know a lot of stuff is going on
but it's all pretty exciting another big
trend to look out for is serverless
functions are kind of running everywhere
now they're clearly run in multiple
cloud providers now that every cloud
provider has a service experience
they're running on premise
thanks to these open-source service
platforms and they could also run in the
edge cloud flares got a great cloud
player worker project lambda has lambda
at edge and we're quickly entering this
world where these these functions can
live all over the place and that's great
because event data is all over the place
so what with all this stuff going on
there's a lot of change a lot of
innovation a ton of options now and
projects how do we adopt this today and
here's kind of the most important
lessons that we've learned over at
serverless Inc first off you know we
talked to you know these enterprise
organizations regularly and they're in a
tough bind a lot of them are kind of
caught in this this adoption challenge
you know they want to avoid lock-in they
will also want total control and
oversight but at the same time they want
to move fast they want to innovate and
many are choosing to kind of DIY their
own service platforms so you know we've
seen several companies working on their
own service platforms for a number of
years now to avoid vendor lock-in and
give them the control and oversight they
need on the other hand we've seen the
cloud providers unrelentingly add
innovative services service offerings to
their whole platform and we've seen a
lot of companies embracing those and
being very successful at delivering
innovation at record pace so how does
one how does an organization kind of
kind of navigate this and this is where
open source especially can save the day
so so what we've learned of course and a
big service principle is that first off
it's all relative to the use case
Einstein actually said this the second
half just got cut off
but you know this is you know something
that's very popular in the service
community and it's just central to the
service culture and that is focused on
the use case focus on the outcome first
not infrastructure and platforms figure
out what is most important to best serve
that use case you know do you need to
move fast you need to be innovative you
need to capture the market or do you
want to kind of avoid lock-in and maybe
some public clouds in general and if you
do that if you run your own platform
kind of at what is the opportunity cost
of doing that the great thing about
Cerberus is that lower overhead appeals
to all types of use cases it's often
used for kind of critical data
processing pipelines back-end services
but also equally used for marketing
projects internal tools random adventure
of an automation business process
automation you know do you really need
to roll out your own platform to do kind
of all this stuff you know maybe not if
the one platform approach is gonna block
you from being able to solve a problem
best you know that's that's not super
that's not good so you could do with a
service a lot of different ways now and
the best way will be revealed always by
focusing on the outcome so focus on that
first and you know what I strongly
recommend is that before adopting any
service platform and again there's so
many great options out there whether
it's AWS or one of these cool open
source service platforms I would
absolutely prioritize investing in tools
that offer vendor and platform choice
and organize your strategy all around
that there are handful of great tools
that do this you know like our service
framework or Tara forms another
fantastic one but these things are gonna
give you options and that's of critical
importance right now and they're also
gonna give you a single experience for
using for using these options and again
this is where open source especially has
to play a big role you know open source
communities have to come up with more
tools like this because you know these
big platforms have big biases you know
towards their platforms and if that
future is running serverless functions
everywhere we need the tool link to help
make that easy so again first focus on
your outcome and then adopt the tools
that will flexibly allow you to deliver
on those outcomes best the future is
uncertain change is constant you know
tools that give you options a
diversified approach should absolutely
be prioritized and further you know
service is all about moving up the staff
to the application level and we think
service is going to evolve these
developer tools in infrastructure in
general and infrastructure provisioning
tools to focus more on the application
level and this is something that this is
a theme that we think about a lot at
Cerberus Inc we're always trying to
figure out how to how to express this
team you know we think software tooling
should be designed more around outcomes
and apps and not infrastructure and this
is also what service is strongly about
we kind of started this with the service
framework and we also have a new project
which we're opening up in a beta in a
few weeks
it's called service components simply
open source reusable vendor agnostic
serverless building blocks
it's a packaging system for application
features or entire applications you know
built using servlets infrastructure
across all vendors you can compose these
building blocks together to rapidly
build apps and these components are very
outcome focused whether it's you know
your data processing pipeline a users
credit API an SMS subscription service
subscription payment service or an
entire service forum or an entire
service ecommerce application you should
be able to compose this stuff together
to build end results with that service
efficiency we're opening this up as a
standalone public beta we're going to
incorporate it into our framework if
it's interesting to you you could go to
service calm and you know sign up for
the newsletter but again focus on your
outcomes and then adopt the flexible
tools that will allow you to best
deliver on those outcomes and after that
lean on community driven standards these
standards the harmonization
conversations are just getting started
in the service space and it's exciting
because it could solve a lot of problems
for example making functions more
portable so that they can move around to
wherever they need to go or event data
more consistent the CNC F is kind of
where these conversations are taking
place there's a service working group
within the CNC F and we're meeting every
Thursday 9:00 a.m. Pacific time to talk
about this stuff the service working
group recently authored a great white
paper talking about service in general
and now they're focused on harmonizing
these service concepts to give users
vendor choice and flexibility first
effort
of the service working group where the
next effort is you know that we found
that a nun controversial starting point
when it comes to harmonization was
around events and we're working on this
this concept called cloud events
it's a specification for for describing
event data in a common way
against herbalists is a story of
function and events this is half that
story an event data is being transported
across environments increasingly and
unfortunately all the platforms that are
publishing events they're kind of
ubiquitous events are everywhere but
they're all publishing them in different
formats which limits the ability to
transform event data wherever you want
it to go mm-hmm so we think this this
might actually have a huge rising tide
effect it could be bigger than
serverless events are kind of bigger
than service at the end of the day it
might affect all of IT but we're kicking
this off in the service working group
because it's part of the service story
it's an essential part there are a ton
of major industry stakeholders involved
now and it's super exciting so if you're
if you're curious about this strongly
recommend you jump in at a wrap-up you
know whether you're adopting service or
you're looking for a role open source
has to play in the service space you
know first off focus on outcomes not
infrastructure that is an important
service principle adopt tools to
flexibly support those outcomes not
tools that kind of support a specific
platform and embrace standards when they
mature or help us build them right now
if any of this sounds interesting to you
here's my contact info you can learn
more about the service framework at
service com and if cloud events is of
interest to you or the service working
group in general go to github.com slash
cloud events there's a ton of
information as how you could join the
effort and start contributing anyway
thank you all for your time and next up
we've got Dan Kahn the executive
director of the cloud native computing
foundation who's going to show you
something special that they've been
working on anyway thanks again
[Applause]
hi there I'm Dan Khan I'm the executive
director of the cloud native computing
foundation I want to really thank Austin
for that great talk and talking about
serverless which is really one of the
most exciting spaces and opensource
right now I also want to thank him for
donating three minutes at the end of his
talk so I could just show you a cool
project that we've been working on at
ciencia and I also do want to thank him
for his leadership with both the service
working group but then particularly
cloud events so quick show of hands how
many people have seen some version of
this document before okay more than half
so this is the cloud native landscape
many people have said that it's
incredibly useful and valuable it has
also been referred to as the hellscape
and so we've gotten a little criticism
for the tyranny of choice for seeming
like it's too complicated and so we went
back and looked at how we could make
this more useful for real enterprises
and vendors and and the end users that
are and the developers that are make up
our cloud Native community and we
decided to do two different follow-on
projects so the first that we're
launching is called the cloud native
trail map and this is a one-page it's
actually portrait but it takes you
through the steps of how you might
approach cloud native and so
containerization and this real focus on
continuous integration continuous
delivery which is arguably the area
that's going to have the very highest
value the biggest return then talks
about orchestration and then as we go
forward you look at some of the other
projects so service meshes are
incredibly hot right now and you have
envoy and linker D and core DNS but
that's not where you want to get started
in this space and we'll actually have
handouts for you of this at the at the
next break and it's also available
online so that was a sort of the zoom
out version of how can you just approach
cloud native and begin thinking about it
and begin learning about it but then for
the practitioners and the folks that are
really eyebrow deep in it we also wanted
to have the zoom in version and so that
is the
interactive landscape that we're
launching here at the conference and you
can actually pull out your phone or your
laptop and try typing this in right now
it's l dot CNC F dot IO or landscape CMC
F dot IO and it will show you the four
hundred and sixty different projects and
products that we're monitoring and
following in this space and so I will go
ahead and I'm no Kelsi Hightower but
just try and do a quick demo for you so
you can see that we show kubernetes
which can goldberg announced that we
graduated yesterday are incubating CN CF
projects our sandbox projects and then a
lot of other logos this has been a
project for the last couple months and
Jim and I and a few other Linux
Foundation folks were traveling through
China three weeks ago Beijing and
Hangzhou Shanghai Shenzhen Hong Kong in
five days and I got the feedback of why
do you keep staring at all these logos
but as I was dealing with data caps this
was the the project that we've been
working on but the part that's
particularly neat about is the ability
to actually zoom in and kind of think
about it in different ways so for
example here's open source projects by
first commit and so we're pulling this
data from github and if I click in I can
see that Postgres was actually found
started 22 years ago but their latest
commit was today which is just such an
extraordinary accomplishment of an open
source project
Mariya DB being a fork of MySQL are both
18 years old and I can click through and
see a lot of other ones and for each of
these I can then pull up the Twitter
info to see what's been going on most
recently the funding info that we're
pulling from crunchbase so you can see
they've raised ten to half a million
dollars and another view if I come here
to open source projects by stars I can
see here's kubernetes at number one with
33 thousand stars but look at that
Austin's project serverless is here is
the fifth entry and we're very happy to
have them as CN CF member and I'll point
out they're three million dollars in
funding according to crunch base so any
of the venture capitalists in the
audience might want
go up and talk to him so I do encourage
you to take a look and if you pop it up
later today it's fun to click those
example filters to look at your
organization and see the projects that
come up and then in any project this
size there's going to be errors in it so
we're really eager to accept pull
requests it's something you can do right
from the github web interface and we can
approve it and get it live almost
immediately so this is really designed
to be a collaborative editing project
and so we do have an updated version of
the landscape with even more logos on it
we now list our kubernetes certified
service providers all the 50 certified
kubernetes platforms and distributions
and everything else and we'll keep
coming out with a new version of this
every month that's gonna map to the
interactive landscape this is also the
server list version of it that was a
project that Austin and everyone else
from the service workgroup worked on so
please feel free to tweet about this if
you have issues or questions or
suggestions please reach out to me at my
email and thanks again to Austin for
giving me those five minutes
[Applause]